[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact most people know the
redwood trees in Northern California are
the tallest trees in the world some
nearing 400 feet this is both true and
somewhat false it's true because right
now the redwoods are the tallest trees
but not long ago that wasn't the case
the tallest non redwood is 379 feet tall
but historical accounts are full of
references to Douglas fir trees 400 feet
high and taller one tree in North
Western Washington is thought to have
been 465 feet tall probably the largest
known tree ever recorded on the planet
and it wasn't alone there are over 100
historical reports of Douglas firs from
300 to 400 feet tall 150 years ago trees
rivaling the height of the modern
redwoods were fairly common even cedar
trees were reported at 300 feet high
sadly because these large virgin trees
had such a valuable straight grain they
were cut down for profit and expansion
did you know the Bible talks about a
tree that was so large its top reached
into the heavens and he could be seen
from a hundred miles away and it was cut
down stay with his friends we'll learn
more on this edition of amazing facts
Bible answers live you're listening to
Bible answers live honest answers to
your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 bible question
the beginning of the program is a good
time to do that once again here's the
number 804 63 72 97 four six three seven
two nine seven with your Bible questions
we are also streaming if you want to
watch what's happening here in the
studio you can simply go to the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page or amazing facts
Facebook page and you can watch and
listen and tell your friends to tune in
right now at the top of the program my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening friends and pastor
Doug let's stop the program with prayer
dear father we thank you that we can
open up your word and study together
this evening and we just ask for your
Holy Spirit to come in God our hearts
and be with those as they listen and be
with us here in the studio as you search
the Scriptures for we ask this in Jesus
name Amen amen
Oh pastor Doug I know you've been up to
the redwoods probably have multiple
occasions I have I driven actually a
minivan drove right through one of the
redwood tree sits up there somewhere and
you always look at these massive trees
it's all inspiring but to think of a a
tree even taller than the redwood and
not that of an uncommon tree I mean that
goes further you still get them today
yeah thinking that one actually grew
that tall I don't suppose they have any
idea how old that tree is well they say
Douglas fir they grow a little quicker
than the redwoods and they had many that
were recorded to be over a thousand
years you've been up to visit our cabin
and the hills so there's some stumps you
know once a tree burns it doesn't rot
very quick and there are some burnt tree
stumps there that are like ten feet
through our Douglas fir and you know
this that wasn't where the tallest ones
were yeah there are some massive there
were some massive trees I would love you
know you ever daydream about if he could
go back in time I I think one of the
things I'd like to do is I'd like to
have been with the Lewis and Clark
expedition when they saw the West and
it's just natural splendor it's early
splendor and the trees that they saw in
those woods it would have really been
something but there's a story in the
Bible about a tree and you find out
about this if you go to Daniel chapter 4
it talks about this famous King
Nebuchadnezzar and he has a vision about
a tree he says in this is in the Book of
Daniel chapter 4 verse 10 I was looking
in vision and behold a tree in the midst
of the earth and its height was great
and the tree grew and became strong and
its height reached to the heavens and it
could be seen to the ends of the earth I
said in my amazing facts 100 miles
because I didn't think people would
believe me if I said this tree could be
seen from the ends of the earth of
course this is a tree envisioned and
later in the vision we don't have time
to read the whole chapter we recommend
it but it basically says that an angel
some messenger from heaven comes and
cuts down the tree he leaves a stump
with a band of bronze and iron seven
years it remains wet with the dew of
heaven and then it sprouts again
nebuchadnezzar his wise man can't tell
him what this dream means and finally
daniel is called and with some
apprehension he finally tells the king
king this this tree is you you have
grown to be a mighty king of a great
empire and all the world is aware of you
and fed by you and nourished and but
your proud and if you don't humble
yourself
Daniel advised the King to break off his
sins by doing righteousness and show
mercy to the poor and might be a
lengthening of your tranquility and so
the King behaved himself for about
another year and then he couldn't resist
and he was walking maybe one day as the
Sun was setting on the balcony there and
babbling and he couldn't resist it says
and this is in verse 28 it says the King
spoke is not this the great Babylon that
I have built for a royal dwelling of my
mighty power for the honor of my majesty
and while the word was still in the
Kings mouth a voice fell from heaven
King Nebuchadnezzar to you it has spoken
the kingdom is departed from you they'll
drive you from man and your dwelling
will be with the beasts of the field and
they'll make you eat grass like an oxen
and seven times meeting seven years will
pass over you until you know the most
high rules in the kingdom of men and
gives it to whomever he chooses and
right after that judgment was pronounced
Nebuchadnezzar basically lost his
reasoning he grovelled around like an
animal until his hair was long and
matted his fingernails grew out and he
was foraging in the fields probably the
hunting range around the palaces like an
animal eating grass and then at the end
of that seven years his reason returned
this was all foretold in prophecy but it
came on Nebuchadnezzar because of his
pride the Bible tells us a haughty
spirit goes before a fall
and at the heart of selfishness is sin
in the middle of sin I think I heard
someone say this yesterday the middle of
sin is a letter I and Nebuchadnezzar had
eye problems he thought about how much
he had accomplished and you know you can
lose it all overnight our problem
everyone is motivated by one of two
things were motivated either by love and
selflessness or selfishness and pride
and everybody struggles with selfishness
all sin is a form of selfishness and
we've got a book that talks about how to
gain the victory over this pride and
selfishness it is a free book I don't
think we've offered this in a long time
but friends if you've not read this book
you ought to ask for it it's free and it
will
be a blessing to you the book is simply
entitled the surrender of self the
surrender of self we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls an ass the number
to call his 808 three five six seven
four seven as one author put it one of
the greatest battles that is ever to be
fought is the surrender of self we have
to get to the point of surrendering all
to Jesus all right no pastor Ross before
we go to the phones I want to give a
shout-out to my dear friend and the
partner this is Karen's birthday I want
to just wish her a happy birthday had a
little celebration at the house before I
came over but she often listens in and
I'm hope she's listening now about happy
birthday dear and yeah it's just been a
delight so all right to the phones all
right we've got our first caller we
listen to we'll stop with Chris in
Florida Chris welcome to the program
yeah hello hi thanks for waiting in your
question Chris excited to help I still
does yes it is some revelation 6 chapter
6 verses 9 and 10 all right I tell you
what I'll read that and I'll let pastor
Ross address it because I know he has a
special love for revelation when he
opened the fifth seal I saw under the
altar the souls of those who had been
slain for the word of God and for the
testimony which they held and they cried
with a loud voice saying how long O Lord
holy and true until you judge and avenge
our blood on those who dwell on the
earth then a white robe was given to
each of them and it was said that they
should rest a little longer until both
the number of their fellow servants and
their brethren who would be killed as
they were was completed are you
wondering if this vision is meaning that
people don't really die but there under
the altar crying my question is we know
what Paul says in the letter of 2
Thessalonians that when we die we are
asleep and waiting for a judgement right
yes but they how do you relate to this
passage there are people believers that
are introduced of God of
yeah absolutely was a good question let
me let me throw a few things out there
first of all remember revelation is a
symbolic book you have a number of
symbols throughout the book of
Revelation including horses galloping
through the sky and you've got beasts
rising up from the sea and from the
earth in Revelation chapter 6 these part
of what we call the seals of Revelation
there's a total of seven each of these
seals represent different time periods
and the fifth seal which is the opening
of it opens up the fifth seal and you
have symbolically martyrs under the
altar and asking how long it's referring
to a time period of severe persecution
that came upon Christians during the
Middle Ages and probably the cry that
many a Christian had during that time of
persecution is Lord how long you can
allow these things to happen now again
we know this is symbolic because you
have these souls under an altar in
heaven and it says that they cry out and
then it says you need to wait a little
while longer and I'm gonna give you
these white robes well we know that
white robes represent something in Bible
prophecy
just as Abel's blood cried out from the
ground for justice of so symbolically
those martyrs their lives or their death
is crying out saying how long will this
persecution continue it did finally come
to an end as you read on in the seals
but there was a time period of about
twelve hundred and sixty years of severe
severe persecution does that help a
little bit Chris okay okay can I just
ask so better to me that people like
Martin Luther and John Haas that is they
are not in presence of God Martin Luther
himself said that when he died he would
sleep until the Lord came and knocked
upon his grave and said wake up dr.
Martin and so Martin Luther even
believed that he would sleep until the
resurrection and the resurrection we
read is following the Second Coming when
the dead in Christ rise jesus said the
hour is coming in which all that are in
the graves John chapter 10 we'll hear
his voice and come forth even Jesus said
to Martha the resurrection in the last
day people don't die and go right to
heaven now if you're believer and you
die
your next conscious thought is the
presence of the Lord because you have no
consciousness of time so for a believer
who dies the next thing he knows is the
resurrection but it hasn't happened yet
for us that live in time you know we
have a study guide called are the dead
really dead that deals with the subject
it's got all the Bible verses and we'll
be happy to send this out to anyone who
calls and asks and Chris or anyone
listening if you'd like to receive this
for free just give us a call the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and
asked for the amazing fact study guide
are the dead rarely did and why are you
they on the phone you might as well ask
for more than just one of the lessons we
have a whole series of lessons dealing
with some very important Bible truths
that's called the Bible school and you
can just ask how can I enroll it's for
free how can I enroll and become a
student in amazing facts Bible school
next caller the behave is Jackie
listening from California Jackie welcome
to the program
hi pastors thank you for having me yes
in your question yes right now I'm
trying to read the books of the law and
that immediately based in sort of
difficult for example in Leviticus 20
verse 10 it talks about when people are
caught in adultery dare to get stoned
but then in those same books of the law
there's such a thing as been offering
since they do sacrifices and I'm just
wondering what sort of sins back then
qualified for sacrifices for sins when
would you stone somebody and when would
they forgive I mean forgiven if they
offered a sacrifice well the the capital
punishment was very rare you know person
if they were killed it's his eye for eye
tooth for tooth if a thief was caught
stealing then they were told to make
restitution fourfold if a person told a
lie that would be a sin offering you
know there were a number of things that
you could do that did not mean capital
punishment if a person could swear
falsely that talked about that and there
was punishment for that but it wasn't
capital crime you know we do have some
examples in the Bible if people have
committed some some or other terrible
sins and they were forgiven you think of
David he falls into this category but he
was repentant and you know
there were consequences that he suffered
but he wasn't stoned he didn't lose his
life so I think the point being here if
if there is still a spirit of rebellion
and a lack of repentance and someone's
just committed to following a path of
lawlessness yes then they were penalties
in this case adultery was stoned people
were stolen so that's when people showed
no sign of repentance a lack of
repentance sort of okay alrighty and
then you've got the woman caught in
adultery also and Jesus in the New
Testament forgave you yeah I don't
condemn you said go and sin no more you
know there's no record there is actually
a record of someone being stoned for
Sabbath breaking but there is no record
of anyone being stoned for adultery in
the Bible okay God was trying these laws
I think were written because God was
trying to preserve the integrity of the
family and marriage so they had a pretty
stiff sentence for violating the
marriage vows now keep in mind the the
law of Moses did not say stoning was a
penalty for fornication if a young man
and a young woman were caught out in the
field together misbehavin they had to
get married yes no and there was even
there they even had if the father wasn't
willing her to marry there was a fine
that was paid for her losing her
chastity every time someone committed
fornication they weren't stoned to death
that was just a severe case of like
taking someone else's wife okay alrighty
thank you Buster and happy birthday
thanks so much appreciate that all right
keep reading thank you all right next
quality behave he's calling from looks
like South Korea Cola from South Korea
welcome to the program to our morning
amazing fact morning thanks for calling
my question is I did a children's story
originally about the creation week and I
was confused about two parts of the
Bible in the book of Genesis chapter 1
verse 1 and 2 and chapter 2 verse 4 to 6
are these description of the condition
of Earth describing the first day of
creation or the
time before the creation week well in in
Genesis 1 it's talking of course about
the the sequence of days that you've got
Genesis 2 the beginning it ties off the
creation week with the Sabbath then it
backs up and it gives more detail of
that creation week because it tells you
about how God made man well God makes
man in chapter 1 but then it tells you
how he makes him in more detail when you
go to chapter 2 verse 7 also explains
what the work of man that explains how
woman was formed but those things happen
on the sixth day of creation so it's
backing up it's like you've read a
newspaper before where you've got the
headline and you read the headline you
get the overview of the story then you
go start reading the details of the
story the Hebrews wrote like newspapers
they gave the headline in the first
sweeping statement then they back up and
they give the detail you might be
wondering why in verse 4 it says Day is
that what you're wondering or it says
and he created in the day that the Lord
God made the heavens and the earth was
that just a 24-hour period is that what
you're wondering I think the reason why
I'm confused is because we typically
think that on the first day the light
was created but Genesis chapter 1 verse
1 and 2 he says God created heaven and
earth and there was there was water
there was earth without form and
darkness was there so is that the
condition before the seven-day creation
or is that the the first day of the
creation week well there was light out
in the universe before God created our
world the Bible tells us God is light
and in him is no darkness so there was a
light in other places but when he comes
to this corner of the cosmos and he
begins creating our world and perhaps
our galaxy and solar system he speaks to
this dark orb and says let there be
light and he begins making our world and
it's talking about that creation that
and the first day he spoke light into
our world because he doesn't even make
the Sun until the fourth day mm-hmm so
God is the light at the beginning when I
was chapter 2 verse 4 through 6 he says
there
there was no vegetation or they
describing any specific day of the
creation week or is this talking about
it is backing up information in chapter
1 verse 1 and 2 are they describing the
same thing yeah I think it's backing up
mm-hm
you know when you see the word day in
verse 4 we're not talking about a
24-hour day like to be talking about in
Genesis chapter 1 sometimes in the Bible
when it says the day that's referring to
the time for example the day of the Lord
it's talking about a time period and
it's saying the history of the heavens
in the earth when they were created in
the day that the Lord God made the earth
and the heavens talking about that time
period when God created the earth
now of course chapter 1 is very detailed
and telling you you know morning and
evening is the first day morning and
evening is the second and so on so we
know it's a literal 24-hour period
chapter 2 is just a summary of when God
created this is when the time when God
created the earth in other words okay so
this is not really like any like
information date with as Christian did
we normally miss that it's not really
included in the creation no I think he's
just backing up and he's talking when he
says created in the day when the Lord
God made the earth and the heavens he's
saying in the time when the Lord God
made it he says this is the history he
said in other words this is the detail
this is the record he's just giving a
little more detail on that I hope that
helps a little bit gee well we sure
appreciate your calling from South Korea
next one of the wave is calling from
Brooklyn New York we have hell on the
phone hello welcome to the program hi
good morning good good evening it's
evening here and I know it's three hours
earlier where you are yeah it's still
evening but thank you for calling your
question my question is about Israel God
made three lights he made the Sun was
the greater light and the moon was the
lesser light and the June was the
Israelite I've never heard that one
before but that's good anyway and what
plan does God half of the Israelites I
know he has a plan
I'm a Jewish believer thank God I'm a
believing you know it wouldn't believe
it for seventy years already Wow
yes I got saved in 1949 and I've been in
Brooklyn ever since I'm 88 at this time
bless your heart
well you know I'm also a Jewish believer
I know you walk by the dog and I'm but
my my mother was not very Orthodox but
she was Jewish
I believe God still has a tremendous
plan I think in the last days God is
going to pour out his spirit and you're
gonna see a revival among a number of
the Jewish people that are going to come
to Jesus like you did and are gonna be
instrumental and help me preach the full
gospel to the people of the world so it
doesn't mean everybody who's Jewish is
all going to be converted because that's
you know God's never worked that way but
I think there's going to be a great
revival among the people they'll
probably be some additional persecution
yes
brother what today su the Jewish people
are looking for their Messiah now they
don't know when they don't want to
believe it's Jesus most of them but
they'll be surprised and Zechariah is it
says what are these wounds and my hands
when he returns the universe script yep
what I received in the house of my
friends absolutely yeah and they're
gonna learn that he was the Messiah and
is the Messiah we both know a number of
people who have come to faith that came
from a Jewish background and it's just
it's always a real thrill when then they
get the whole picture of what the
scriptures are all about there's nothing
quite like it well thank you so much for
your call we appreciate that how and we
do have a book we'll offer you a free
copy
it's called spiritual Israel written by
a fellow Jew in myself the number to
call for that is 883 five six seven four
seven and again just asked for the book
called spiritual Israel will be able to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
have you ever wondered how can I share
Jesus with my Jewish friends amazing
faxes recently produced a fascinating
three-part DVD series called is Jesus
kosher for Jews in these new programs
three Jews Steve Wahlberg Jeff sir
Minsky and myself relate our personal
encounter with a Christian fate so pick
up a copy today for yourself and share
one with your Jewish friends call 800
five three eight seven 275 or visit us
at AAF bookstore com to get yours for
life-changing Christian resources visit
AAF bookstore calm next caller that we
have looks like we have a net calling
from the Virgin Islands a networking
program hi good night pass don't hide in
Iraq together and prosper wha good night
evening thank you for calling thank you
ready Daniel chapter twelve forty one
and I've been having a little trouble
trying to understand there's like three
different times mention in Daniel
chapter 12 and I'm trying to understand
justice um this time that has never been
before have it was it passed I mean has
it caught already oh well most of then
there's three time periods that are
given in Daniel 12:1 is 1260 now 1260 is
a time period and if just want to let
you know Annette if we don't get through
your whole question before our break
we'll come back to you because we have a
break coming up in two minutes but real
quick there are three time periods the
first is 1260 1260 years is three and a
half prophetic years in other words in
three and a half Jewish years you have
1260 days and a day in Jewish are in
prophecy equals a year Jesus taught for
1260 days from his baptism to his
crucifixion the disciples then preached
1260 days from Christ till Stephen was
stoned
you've got 1260 days of famine in the
days of Elijah it's three and a half
years a time period appears many times
but there is a special three and a half
year period of persecution in the
for 1260 years because if a day is a
year in prophesy 1260 days is going to
be 1260 years from 538 to 1798 the other
two prophecies in Daniel 12 are relating
to that they're talking about the the
cleansing of the sanctuary and a time
when a great message will go out to the
world to prepare for them basically the
last stage of the church
yeah just after that a little bit the
1335 that you have and 1290 years a
number of Bible scholars have seen in
that the conversion of a fringe King
Clovis king of the Franks that sort of
opened the way up for the papal power
not only to have religious influence but
also political influence and you know
you look back in history you find out
one of the biggest supporters of the
papacy was the kingdom of France during
the Dark Ages that was the birth of the
Holy Roman Empire so hey we're going to
take a break Annette and we'll maybe do
a follow-up question hope that helps a
little don't go away friends more
questions coming
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible the
updated hardcover version is available
at its lowest price ever and includes
the complete set of amazing facts 27
study guides plus a Bible numbers and
symbols charts and eight pages of
colorful maps this best-ever Bible gives
you a biblical cyclope dick index words
of Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five thirty eight seventy two seventy
five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 mning on the
internet if you are watching on Facebook
it's on the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
as well as the amazing facts Facebook
page you can there listen and watch for
what it's worth my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and just
before the break pastor like we were
talking to Annette in virgin island she
was asking about some time periods I'd
be finding Daniel chapter 12 and we were
talking during the break it would be
good if we had a little book that kind
of summarized some of these time periods
but unfortunately we don't have one
available at the moment that we could
share with our listeners so yeah you
know a lot of people when they read
Daniel 12 so much of Daniel is talking
about these kingdoms and this beast
power that would be persecuting he's
wrapping that up here in Daniel 12
mm-hmm of the final terminology that
Daniel uses in the last chapter people
are thinking is there some future
fulfillment to Daniel chapter 12 and
typically we take the historic approach
in our understanding that these things
are all in the
right now as job said wisdom does not
will not perish from the earth with us
and others and we don't know everything
so that is a difficult chapter he got
more time prophecies in Daniel 12 than
any other book in the Bible I'm
wondering if we could direct him to
something you know I just actually my
family was talking about Daniel 12 last
night while we put together a puzzle I
printed out a chart you can go online
you can print out a chart that gives the
historic interpretation of Daniel 12 who
is pretty good I hope that will help a
little bit on that and we appreciate
your patience in your call
okay the nice color that we have let's
see we have Edison calling from
California Edison welcome to the program
Hey hi thanks for calling my question is
why didn't Jesus warn Adam and Eve Eve
that Satan would defeat them why didn't
Jesus or God warn Adam and Eve that the
devil was going to be out there to
deceive them well hey we don't have
every conversation in Genesis between
God and Adam and Eve and I think that
Jesus did warn them and say now be
careful we've got an a fallen angel a
rebellious angel that is roaming through
the universe and he's trying to deceive
people stay away from that bad tree and
you'll be okay but the devil went into
the tree and he possessed the Serpent
and he tempted and so I think that Jesus
did warn them they didn't take it very
seriously just like Jesus has warned us
sometimes like our parents sometimes
warned us to don't play with fire or get
burned whatever it is and we don't
always listen how old are you Addison
how old am I I'm eight
hey Joe good you're asking good deep
Bible questions you read your Bible
everyday yeah good for you
well it did that every morning I read
that's right good for you that's good
well hopefully that helped answer the
question a little bit but I do think
that God warns them that do they needed
to avoid that tree and that the devil
was going to try and trick them and it
didn't they didn't listen to the warning
appreciate your call thank you Addison
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm or call one
eight hundred five three eight seven two
seventy-five next quarter behalf is
Christie listening from New Mexico
Christie welcome to the program thank
you yeah you're the your on and your
question okay my question is about the
prophecies and I keep hearing about the
twenty five twenty from Leviticus 26 and
I've been studying it and I keep coming
across the 2300 day prophecy but never
anything about twenty five twenty can
you expound on where this is found or if
it's about well there's there's a
handful of people out there that take
that prophecy you say Leviticus 26 you
know basically I think if you if you
take a day for a year in prophecy seven
years has two thousand five hundred and
twenty days in it if I'm not mistaken
isn't that 1216 1260 is twenty five
twenty they're they're taken like that
seven years you find in Daniel four and
it may also be in Leviticus 26 and
they're trying to use as a template to
set a date for the second coming and you
know I think Jesus is really clear that
we shouldn't be studying the prophecies
to try and figure out a day an hour he
said no man knows the day or the hour of
my coming you know we've got to be very
careful about that I don't put a lot of
stock in that my friend Steve Wahlberg
has written a book I don't think we
carry we probably ought to get a few so
we can make him available but he writes
a book on explaining the twenty five
twenty if you go to you look up
Whitehorse media and I think that you'll
find a book there that you can get
through Steve will Burke and he answers
and I agree with his answers on that on
the twenty five twenty Thank You Christy
keep studying appreciate it
we've got Caleb listening in Long Island
New York Caleb welcome to the program
hello hello doug batchelor that's no
better yes how are you doing thank you
for calling I'm good you guys you have
been very inspirational to me thank you
so much written but my question is I was
talking to one of my
she knows a Bible but like my thing is
something confused me it's about Jesus
Christ in Revelation John 3:14 it says
that Jesus is like of course creation of
Oakleigh is the first of all creation
what does that mean exactly because I I
watch a lot of your sermons and says
Jesus not created I believe Jesus was
not created I just want to understand
what the Bible means by all right hey
thank you very much Cael appreciate your
question you know there are some folks
out there and among them of course the
Jehovah Witnesses do not believe in the
divinity of Christ they think that Jesus
was a created being and the first let me
just address that and I'll go to the
verse of course God says all things that
were made were made by him meaning the
first thing that was created was created
by Jesus so when it talks about the
beginning of the creation of God the
beginning of the creation of God
happened through Christ God through
Christ made all things the Bible tells
us that God is love well you can't have
love without more than one being so
Jesus has never existed with the father
it also says in Revelation I forget what
chapter if it's 2 or 3 pastor Ross where
he says Alpha and Omega
all right Christ is basically from
everlasting to everlasting now that's
pretty clear that your eternal and one
of the definitions of God is he is
omnipresent all-knowing and God is
eternal he always has been he always
will be and so Jesus is not a creature
he is a creator all life begins with him
so what it talks about the beginning of
the creation of God it's not like Jesus
was the first creation the first
creating that happened happened through
Christ mm-hmm all things as you
mentioned in John chapter 1 all things
were made by him but without him was not
anything made that was made so it's just
I guess Revelation chapter 3 in
particular he's just reaffirming the
fact that Christ is the creator even in
the very beginning Christ was there he
was creating and the verse that we have
in Revelation chapter 1 talking about
Jesus being the Alpha and the Omega is
Revelation chapter 1 verse 8 and it's
also repeating rev Li
in chapter 1 verse 11 hey appreciate
your question Caleb and hope that helps
a little bit thank you for calling Caleb
there there's a book that we will make
available for free if you'd like a copy
and it's called the Trinity is it
biblical because it talks there about
the everlasting nature of Jesus the
number to call for that is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again you can answer the book on the
Trinity
we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls we've got Phil
listening in New York Phil welcome to
the program thank you very much how you
guys are doing a great job I was looking
at the internet a few articles on the
internet couple weeks ago by
knowledgeable people they all say
essentially the same thing that the two
Jewish temples were not where tradition
has it not in that plateau where you
find the Dome of the rock but in fact
they were located in the City of David
which is outside of the walls of East
Jerusalem
strangely enough now they are doing
excavations there what do you think
about that is it possible that people
have been getting it wrong and the
temples are actually outside of the
walls of East Jerusalem
well it's interesting both pastor Ross
and I were there looking at that
excavation site
what last April or in April year a year
ago April it is fascinating the the
things they're discovering there that
site is not very far from the
traditional site for the temple and
history tells us that the temple in the
time of Solomon was like 42 acres I was
reading this morning how that place was
chosen just before the program just
before we went on the air are selling
pastor Ross I did this study this
morning about the place where the temple
was located it's interesting how God
arranges these things there was when
David numbered Israel because of his
pride he was saying how big is my
government how big is my country my
soldiers a plague came on Israel and the
angel of the Lord was basically going
through the country and thousands were
dying and and David saw the angel of the
Lord above Mount Zion with a sword drawn
and the place was particularly called
the threshing floor of Ornan
the angel stopped slaughtering there
because David bought the threshing floor
and he made sacrifice there to the Lord
that place was later designated because
David had bought it threshing for is a
big square area where you thresh wheat
it became the place for the temple and
David may have bought up other
surrounding property I don't think
that's very far from where you find the
Temple Mount today you know exactly
where the footprint of Solomon's
original temple was was that then moved
during the time of Ezra and Nehemiah
stemple that was later refurbished by
Herod you know it's it's hard to say I
have always believed the original site
because I was there years ago I went
into the mosque of Omar you've probably
seen it I saw the tunnel that took the
blood down to the Kidron Valley you know
whether Herod when he renovated the
temple moved the footprint I don't know
for me the important thing is that it
sits there on Mount Zion somewhere the
relevant consideration may be if in fact
the temples were not where you find the
Dome of the rock now I was in it myself
- that may pave the way for the
construction of is there a temple right
now do you believe that a third temple
needs to be built before Jesus comes I
have no idea I tell you the truth I'm a
Christian so I simply could not speak
about that nor am i knowledgeable but
it's just interesting that people are
saying tradition has taken the place of
history in regard to where people
believe the temples were so that's why I
yeah it's it's a good question
and that does frequently happen where
you know people pick a traditional site
and they learn little do a little more
research and they learn things are wrong
I personally I'm inclined to agree with
the scholars that think that I do
believe that this they found the City of
David or some of the original City of
David but David greatly expanded the
Kingdom by the time of Solomon and
that's why I believe that the temple
went outside on that hill where the
threshing floor was thank you for your
call Phil we've got Stewart listening
from New Jersey steel welcome to the pro
are you good your question tonight my
questions I faster Doug Batchelor I
wanted to know what happened to those
who have never heard the gospel
are you wondering does that mean that
everybody who has not heard or believes
the gospel will they be lost that's what
I was wondering because I have family
members who don't know about the gospel
they run fake well you're not alone you
know Jesus said that why does the gate
that leads to destruction and few there
be that find it but I think there will
be some exceptions so we've got to be
careful too about saying that you know
all these people that live in foreign
countries who have never heard the
gospel are all automatically doomed to
destruction you know there are some
people who walk up to the light they
walk in the light that has shed on their
path
God judges every man according to his
works you read in Revelation chapter one
you know God looks on the heart he
judges people what really brings about a
person's can conversion is the Spirit of
God and in understanding the the
wonderful message of the good news we
need to pray for our friends and loved
ones family that may not know the gospel
that they'll hear it because that's the
that's the fastest well the only way
anyone's gonna get to heaven is through
Jesus I know I hope God don't hold this
against me but it just doesn't seem fair
that those who have never heard the
gospel will be sent to hell God will
just send them to hell and even though
they didn't know well you know there's a
lot of people that we're gonna are going
to be saved that maybe did not have an
opportunity because they walked in the
light that they had that's the exception
usually let me mention a verse we
actually mentioned early on in the
program but I think it's important we
talk about the subject Zechariah chapter
13 verse 6 it says and one will say to
him speaking to Christ what are the
wounds between your arms then he will
answer these are the ones or the wounds
that are received in the house of my
friends so apparently it's talking about
a group of people that are saved and yet
they haven't heard the whole Gospel
story mmm they lived up to all the life
they had and God judge them based upon
that
they still saved by Jesus but they might
not have all the details of the gospel
clearing they might it's interesting
that when Christ began his ministry his
first sermon in his home church he
references to non-jews that will be in
heaven they a syrophoenician woman a
Canaanite woman and a name and the leper
and he says they're gonna be in the
kingdom and even Christ said many will
come from the east and the west and sit
down with Abraham Isaac and Jacob
you know we've got to be careful not to
judge anybody because we don't know
people's heart and their experience you
know the Safa fastest way to redeem
people that are lost is going to be the
gospel and even those who are saved who
maybe didn't hear the story of jesus are
still saved by Jesus I thank you Stuart
we appreciate that question and hope it
helps a little
did you know amazing facts has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight forty four two one five seven
thousand we've got Rob listening in
Florida Rob welcome to the program
evening so my question you gentlemen
kind of touched on this a little bit
earlier with what's one of the other
questions but so when Jesus took on
human flesh as a baby and came into the
earth I'm assuming that you know Mary
being his biological mother and God the
Father was obviously his his father but
given that Mary would have been his
biological mother that he would have had
certain physical characteristics that it
would have resembled his mother like any
other child that that comes into the
world
so prior to coming to earth when Jesus
still existed what would he have been
like would he have had a human type
physical body and have resembled some
stuff as
a grown man human being Jesus or what
would if he had looked like or been like
prior to coming to earth if you will and
then in the same way when he was
resurrected would he would his
resurrected body been similar to his
human body or would he have gone back to
whatever it was prior to coming to earth
so but if an unusual question but just
kind of curious yeah well you know you
actually and pastor Ross might look up
the verse and Daniel I'll take you to
the one that's in Revelation chapter 1
when Jesus appears to John he appears is
a glorious creature as hair is like wool
is flesh is gleaming with light you know
I don't know that you would say oh yeah
Jesus he looked like he was you know
more Samoan than Hawaiian I think man
has originally made in the image of God
so Jesus in the resurrection is probably
not in the image of man meaning no
particular person I do agree that when
Jesus was born as a baby that he
probably bore the characteristics of a
Hebrew child and had some similarities
to his mother and maybe even to his
father his earthly father in the
resurrection that disciples did not
immediately recognize him you read the
story of the road to Emmaus but when
their eyes were open they knew who he
was but he still looked human he had
scars in his hands pastor Ross you know
sometimes people wonder well what did
God look like before what did Christ
looked like before he came to the earth
well we know according to Genesis there
man was created in God's image we read
in Revelation with reference to God the
Father he seated upon the throne he has
a scroll in his in his right hand so
there are definite similarities as far
as what God looks like what Christ would
look like his reference to man God made
man in His image but I think the
remarkable thing is that when Jesus took
upon himself humanity he forever is
bound with the human race even though he
is of course glorified he has glorified
body but he's still connected with us
and that's the Marvel of the Incarnation
mm-hm so hope that helps a little bit
Rob it's a great question you know I
think that Jesus he is like pastor oz
was saying forever married to the human
race through the Incarnation and we'll
have a human form because originally we
were made in his form mm-hmm a next one
that we have is cristela listening from
Michigan cristela welcome to the program
hi hello good evening I've been waiting
thanks for your patience yes I have a
question because I it's been really
bothering me for like four weeks and I
feel like God it's really calling me to
do a missionary in the Philippines but I
just want to know what is the you know
how do you determine God's will yes well
I'll give you a couple of points
biblical principles and how do you know
God's will for your life first of all if
you know the ten commandments makes a
real good template for what's right and
wrong but supposing you have several
good options how do you know what his
plan is there are several things that
we're going to send you a free book if
you call it's called how do you know the
will of God our determining the will of
God if you ask for our book on the will
of God they'll send that to you there
are 12 points that we give some of them
are things like what does the scripture
say about what your desire or your
options are get Christian counsel Psalm
37 says he'll give you the desires of
your heart is the Lord putting a desire
in your heart sometimes we think oh I
can't do that because I want to do it we
always think God wants us to do what we
don't want to do sometimes God is giving
you a desire to do something and you're
usually going to be real good at what
you have that passion for are there
providential openings are you seeing the
doors are opening and other doors are
closing that are kind of nudging you
forward sometimes God leads us through
Providence like that through your Bible
study through Christian counsel through
Providence through the promptings of the
Holy Spirit in your life and I think I
give about a dozen ways that you can
help determine the will sometimes it
means you wait and pray until you know
for sure
we'll be happy to send you that book and
God will guide you about what he wants
you to do again the number to call for
the book is just simply eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again you can ask for the book
called determining the will of God and
will be happy saying that a matter of
fact she if you want even praying a long
time you can read that for free online
yeah just go to the amazing effects
website just amazing facts or go calm
you know what even I'm learning Google
is you just type in determining the will
of God Doug Batchelor it'll come up yeah
we've got mold listening in Florida mo
welcome to the program
yes good evening pastor Duggan and I
really enjoy your program my station
here in Florida I've been listening to
you for about a year now comes on in the
morning and evening I try to listen at
least once and sometimes twice I've
really looked forward to your amazing
facts it's a research you do to get
those that's interesting but anything
the reason I'm calling I have a dear
friend that goes to my church and she
believes she said in reincarnation and I
told her well that's not biblical but I
couldn't really give her a verse of
scripture that couldn't explain that to
work you know more I got a verse for you
right here I it's I think it's pretty
clear Hebrews chapter 9 verse 27 if you
want to write that down it says as from
Hebrews 9 verse 27 it is appointed for
man once to die but after that the
judgment
yes that was in my mind but I couldn't
remember which one it was
okay Hebrews 9 verse 27 thank you so
much and you just you tell your your
friend there actually is one
resurrection one reincarnation it's
called the resurrection but you've come
for everyone not as you don't come back
as Napoleon you come back as you then
you you know answer to God for the life
that you've lived so the devil would
love I used to believe in reincarnation
and the devil would love for you to
think that you can just keep on coming
back but the silly thing about the
theory of reincarnation I always
grappled with is I thought what good is
it for me to say I'm going to come back
as another person or a cow or whatever
if I don't remember this
like how am I gonna know that it's me
that can you learn yeah yeah so it never
made any sense this circle of life
business but hey hope that helps a
little bit mo and we do have a book that
talks about are the dead really dead it
talks about death and judgment and you
can get that as well as your verse that
you you got that was very helpful and
past that I can look at the time you
don't have time to take another call but
wondering mind so that book if they if
they want the book it's eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
for the study guide are the dead really
did you were gonna say I just gonna add
there's a lot of additional resources
that we have had the amazing facts
website that a number of subjects all
the books we offering that are available
to read online as well just go to the
amazing facts website and go to our free
library and you can look up all the
different things that we have we also
have a number of videos sermons dealing
with different subjects that you can
also take a look at at the website very
good hey thanks so much friends for
tuning in tonight we do have some
important announcements that will follow
and keep us in your prayers if you want
to keep us on the air go to amazing
facts and click donate
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm
what if you could know the future what
would you do what would you change to
see the future you must understand the
past Alexander the Great becomes king
when he's only 18 but he's a military
prodigy a hundred and fifty years in
advance Cyrus had been named wrong was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined the Gospel writers see his
death as a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by Pastor
Doug Batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we've built churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming a ministry partner please
visit our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]